j'ai cinq ans du voyage c'est un rêve
que l'on met aux enchères le mythique
transatlantique le normandy attire
toujours les curieux près de 2000
photographies et documents sont en vente
et cet amoureux du paquebot normandie
est ici pour enrichir sa collection
il découvre infos insolites ils furent
est examinent chaque détail à l'affût de
la perle rare
ce patient depuis plus de 25 ans je
collectionne beaucoup et pour moi c'est
le un peu le symbole de la france dès la
fin des années 30
j'ai d'autres choses à un téléphone j'ai
une plaque de cameline et brochures
maquette c'est magnifique
c'était vraiment dans les années 30 la
vitrine des arts décoratifs français et
qui étaient regardés admirée partout
dans l'ue c'est vraiment un navire
ambassades façade du coup le normandie
dès sa première traversée de
l'atlantique en 1935 devient une légende
française
il est le paquebot le plus grand le plus
luxueux le plus rapide
mais il ne naviguera que quatre ans
réquisitionné au début de la guerre il
coulera dans le port de nous c'est une
collection très intéressante parce
qu'elle reprend la chronologie du
paquebot elle est très complète et
cohérente
on parle des chantiers de penhoët
jusqu'à malheureusement la démolition et
l' incendie
en fait on a oui une tradition qui
s'écoule dans le temps et qui fait que
la passion l'envié existe toujours
le normandie ce paradis flottant près de
80 ans après sa destruction fait
toujours voyager
[Musique]